Believing that the world is
progressive, it's moving forward,
helps me continue
when I want to give up.
Ryan Matthews had been 17
at the time that he got arrested
and charged with first degree murder
and faced the death penalty.
On Mother's Day, we were sitting
there in court with Ryan's mum
when the jury returned
the verdict of death on her child.
I felt like I'd failed in the
one task that I'd been given.
It felt like the most
hopeless moment.
After Ryan was convicted of murder
and sentenced to death,
that’s when we actually started
to work on his case.
Ryan spent five years on death row.
This one here is Ryan when he was
released from death row in 2004.
The beauty of the story for me
was that in 2008
his sister got married
and asked me to come
and be her bridesmaid at her wedding
and Ryan was her husband's best man.
And so we got to walk down
the aisle of the church,
the man that I'd first met,
or the boy that I'd first met
when he was sentenced to death.
And I got to walk down the aisle of
the church at his sister's wedding.
I can tell you the story
in a couple of minutes,
but that whole thing took nine years,
1999 to 2008, to the wedding.
And there were so many points
in that that I wanted to give up.
And the thing that motivated me back
was always being in touch
with Ryan and his family.
And so the people in all of this
are the things that bring me
back when I want to give up.
One of the most
important things I've learnt,
and this has continued over my life,
is choose your role models carefully.
I faxed the office, it was before
there was email, in New Orleans
and sent my CV which
had probably nothing on it
and said I want to come
work with Clive Stafford Smith
then was really surprised
that no-one got back to me.
And I think my parents said,
"Well maybe you should phone."
And that felt uncomfortable.
I was young,
I guess I didn’t feel confident
but I did phone up.
And my CV had been put on the top
of some filing cabinet somewhere
and the office manager
dug it out and said,
"Yeah sure, turn up, why don’t
you turn up in the summer?"
Choosing my role model carefully
was really important.
I could become the kind of lawyer
that I always wanted to be
by learning from him.
I've always been the small person
taking on the big government
and that can often be
a really scary thing.
But the reason why we have
the story of David and Goliath
is that the small guy
can make the change.
So one of the things
that's always helped me
is quotes or poems that inspire me.
And every day there'll be something
that will motivate me or focus me
and it just makes me feel connected
to other people's struggles.
One of the ones that we always use
in our work with young people
is a Martin Luther King quote,
"The arc of history is long
but it bends towards justice."